la mairie ça c'est une joue bach dessus
on trouve à 100 d'études
hautement aphrodisiaques paraît-il
mi clown ni magicien le gourou de cette
troupe en chaussures de marche est venu
dispenser ses conseils aux jardins de
cocagne de magny les hameaux samedi au
menu et à toutes les sauces les plantes
sauvages
beaucoup prennent des notes certains des
photos les autres boivent littéralement
ses paroles mêmes les connaisseurs font
des découvertes alors livre moi dans ma
campagne est un enfant c'était l'arbre à
ne pas toucher est aujourd'hui bien on
me dit que les baies rouges sont
comestibles
voilà soixante trois ans c'est une
première
et bien souvent les plantes sauvages
sont autant médicinales que gustatives
des alicaments qui datent de milliers
d'années la grande consoude là en
particulier pour les conclusions et
c'était les traumatismes c'est
intéressant ça m'arrive souvent donc
voilà ça c'est très très intéressant
pour ça effectivement à la vapeur je
préfère mais cru
à merveille dans les tableaux
on va peur en cataplasme en infusion ou
en canapé pour eux les herbes folles
deviennent des trésors à la découverte
d'un patrimoine discret connu de nos
ancêtres depuis la préhistoire les
oubliés de la plupart d'entre eux n'ont
aujourd'hui
le but de comprendre que l'on piétaille
très souvent dans son jardin une carte
des menus extrêmement exhaustive pour
parler de manière pompeuse mais
effectivement les mauvaises herbes
n'existe pas et la berce lortie depuis
son lit par exemple sont bien plus
nutritionnel que la viande tout
simplement aussi et j'ai vu un mélange
de jeunes hommes de 20 et de lierre
terrestre passer au mixeur et filtrer
c'est remarquable c'est vraiment injuste
hâtivement mais c'est
dimanche prochain en atelier sera
consacré au jardin mandala sur
inscription pour tout comprendre sur les
subtilités des potagers en forme de roue